Oh Friday follies Amtrak Joe's latest
gaffe I'm seeing classic Bernie video
and a fashion-conscious
principal joining us with all the new
details is Raymond Arroyo Fox News
contributor all right Raymond let's
start with Biden's latest bloop Laura
when you are running as a Democrat in
the Democratic Party of today you have
to connect with the african-american
community but there are probably better
ways to do it than the one Biden shows
at a rally in Des Moines this week we
said look put together a program for us
where we can teach people how to code so
when they went out literally into the
hood the vast majority of women of color
know with more than a high school degree
almost 1/3 of only had a GED literally
in the hood you can't say that there
were audible groans when he said we went
literally in the hood you know given his
track record with racially insensitive
things the stuff he said about Obama
being articulate and clean and bright
he's got to watch himself here this is
when you need Jill Biden next to him say
spring yeah the community
don't say hood no he can't say hood
other people can say hood but people who
live in the inner city if they want to
say hood but I are you the language
police now fine here you're reacting to
what others are react ok so now oh there
is groans or gonna tell you what you
can't say I'm gonna we're gonna put you
all in Chains and say things about
people at Dunkin Donuts and then we said
that would be crucified oh yeah yeah
yeah no there was a new Bernie Sanders
video that surfaced this week political
on earth to show that the been socialist
mayor of Burlington Vermont shot in the
1980s by you guys say to a teenage no
well it looks like the 1880s it was
appropriately called Bernie speaks with
the community here he is with a group of
children hold it hold it hold all right
now one second one second hold it
but who knows about cocaine anyone ever
seen cocaine hold it one at a time what
about cocaine all right did you know you
you look like somebody on back in the
future okay there the other guy it
looked like the other guy you know the
other guy is that he looks like that guy
oh my god it looks like Doc Brown and
Christopher Lord look this is like a
very mean-spirited
art Linkletter remember lordling letter
used to sit with children this could
have been called socialist say the
darndest thing now he went on Bernie was
like a roving reporter through his town
as mayor and there was a moment where he
was he became kind of Burlington's
answer to Joan Rivers on the red carpet
hmm he fought off my saying it's an
interesting hairdo lipstick is also very
interesting what does your dress mean
what does it say it's just basically
saying to heck with society the heck
with minority one thing to the mayor to
heck with law and order I don't like the
way societies run oh my god she's now
she's now an account manager at Goldman
Sachs it's interesting listening to this
Bernie Sanders I didn't realize he made
film strips for children before he was
my he's kind of a liberal roving Michael
Moore before Michael insult dog except
it looks like the back to the future now
very peculiar I've got to get to this
finally the principle of James Madison
High School in Houston sparked charges
of elitism and racism when she sent a
letter home saying the school would be
enforcing a new dress code for parents
so this is a white privileged woman I
bet making no no no great we'll drive
hold your fire this is what she outlawed
and then we're gonna go to her she
outlawed this parental garb pajamas of
any kind sagging pants men and
undershirts uncovered leggings Daisy
Duke shorts and hair rollers principal
Carlotta Brown defended her clothing
policy when anyone walks and we have
impressionable children
and we have to model what we want them
to know you have to show them what is
right what is correct for example you
don't wear swimsuit to school you wear
it to the beach it's about academic
excellence I like this and you know what
else she's I like her she said you are
your T child's first parent and first
teacher rather you are what you model
what you wear they're gonna wear I like
that she's enforcing this how many times
have you and I've been on a plane
oh no we're here comes a guy in a
t-shirt and his pajama bottoms with
flip-flops or what do you call them
slippers slippers on the plane this
happens all the time
and if you sit in a parking lot of
school parking lot you'll see some
sights I'm glad she's I love the fact
that women are saying heck Ron you can't
you're better than that
I mean woman I'll say you're judging me
and how dare you judge me this is my
fashion truth well some fashion truths
should be kept to themselves like the
enemy they not just an idea of things
that people were wearing to the school
that I think irritated principal
Carlotta things like that very tight
mid-drift and the tight leggings or when
men show up looking like this this is
what they want we want the pajama the I
it's always the fuzzy pajama binder
where you run into all kinds of problem
now look just a quick reminder everyone
I'm gonna be signing copies of will
Wilder at the Fairfax Virginia Barnes
and Noble on May 4th tomorrow and in New
Orleans at Octavia books on May 11th
come see me tomorrow in Northern
Virginia details at Raymond Arroyo
dot-com